what is going on everybody welcome to
the 3rd and data analysis with Python
and panda's tutorial video in this video
what we're going to be talking about is
pandas IO which is short for
input/output so with pandas you can
input/output multiple data formats so up
until now we've shown you know IO with
the API where you didn't really actually
have to do anything as far as i/o is
concerned and then we showed in the
second video doing it with dictionary
again no fancy i/o is required but when
you start thinking about how you're
going to handle a csv text the HDF file
XLS and so on or HTML SQL each file has
to be handled a little different but
with pandas typically the input/output
is still going to be just one line it's
going to be into a data frame and you're
ready to go no different than how you
would handle anything else so that's
what we're going to kind of talk about
here's how to use the i/o kind of
framework and what you can do how you
can import and main things change the
index and so on so anyways what we're
going to do is we're going to bop on
over to this website quand elle comm qu
aandl comm for this tutorial you won't
need an account or anything you can stay
logged out eventually you will need an
account because we're going to use an
API key and stuff it's totally free they
do have premium stuff but we'll just use
all the free stuff so anyway you might
want to think about making an account
with them so we're going to use them
relatively quickly but not for this
tutorial so when you go to kondal
basically what they have is just day
sets galore for like everything ok and
what's nice is their data sets are
pretty well normalized they cuando also
has an API module well an API but also a
module that works with their API again
in this tutorial we won't be using that
but soon we will and it's actually
really easy to use and but even if you
didn't use it
the quantal is really simple to grab
data from anyway we're going to get into
housing prices in real estate and all
that so we're going to pretend that
we're billionaire investors so that's
what we'll do so first let's say you're
looking for a house in Austin Texas so
maybe we would look for like you know
housing prices 77006 that's the zip code
for Austin now um least I think it is
we'll find out soon enough so here we go
we got Zillow home value index median
price for that zip code that's from 2008
onward hoping we could find a longer one
not really we have some longer indexes
here from 1975 that's okay we don't need
a lot of data we're not going to really
do much so let's say you click on this
one so these are this is your basically
your home value index for the zip code
and so as you can see really fairly
recently the home prices have been
pretty much skyrocketing so from here
you can do a few things export data this
would be from any of the here first of
all you have the code here and then this
would be if you're using say you're
using the Python library which we'll
talk about later you don't worry about
that out but you would click on this and
bam that's the code you would get and it
automatically stuffs it into a panda's
data frame awesome now we'll leave this
aside for now and what we're looking for
is download we're going to go to
download and then you can choose XML
JSON Excel CSV well just so happens that
pandas can import all of these data
types we're just going to use CSV for
now we'll click that BAM you get the
download will drag over the tutorials
right here and I'm just going to click
and drag this into here now
the next thing that I do want to cover
actually let's go to our friend
google.com and let's say you are curious
about something with pandas well pain
actually has relatively decent
documentation so we could say pandas io
and here we go you got your IO tools
here these are basically all of the data
types that we can read in pickle
clipboard strategy BQ or Stata HTML
message pack J's on SQL HD have Excel
CSV and you can even put it back out so
this is to read from this is to okay so
you can get all kinds of information
here also this is basically the
documentation here this just all the
stuff
panas can do for you we'll be covering
most of this stuff here but if there's
something else you want to do with
pandas chances are you can do it it's
just it's somewhere hidden in these
documents moving that now you now we've
got the CSV this is where this is the
script we're working on right now so
this is in the same directory now I'm on
Windows I can reference this locally if
you're on Linux and maybe you're
executing from the shell or something
like this you may need to get the full
path I'm going to specify just a local
path but you may need to give the full
path depending on how you're executing
this code so moving this over the first
thing that we would do to read the CSV
well first of all we actually have to
import pandas so import pandas as PD as
usual now we're going to say DF equals
PDE to underscore CSV as to read the CSV
but again if you were reading maybe an
excel like an XLS or xlsx boom you would
use this if you're reading hdf5 file
read hdf SQL would be a little different
you have to make the connection in all
of that and anyway and then HTML is a
little different too we may touch on
that briefly but anyway moving along
read CSV now you specify the path uh so
like I said we're just gonna use the
local path so I'm gonna just do this
copy
come over here paste done now crane TF
head and we get eventually hopefully
maybe a data frame boom now of course we
see that date is not our index and we're
being assigned this kind of net index so
what we can do is we can close out of
here and we can do RDF dot set index and
don't forget we have to say in place
equals true or redefine the data frame
so DF dot set underscore index we're
going to set it to the date column and
we're set in place equals true and then
let's go ahead and DF dot to underscore
CSV and we're going to save it to
we're just going to call it new CSV -
dot CSV okay so that will actually save
to a CSV our information I pull up the
where we are Mouse is there we go so
we'll save it run that and that outputs
it to CSV which we can see new CSV -
here we could open that up we could look
at it if we wanted but that should be
our data now I'm going to move this over
feel free to open that and peek around
if you want but it's a CSV file so and
it should have your all your information
in fact let's pop it open right so
you've got your header date and then
value and there's all your data so then
just so you know it's a successful CSV
moving this over now what what we're
going to do is we're going to read it
back in so we're going to redefine data
frames so we're going to say da equals P
dot read underscore CSV and we're going
to read in news news CSV to CSV now
we're going to say print EF dot head and
we're going to see though what hands up
happening is we're back to having date
as just regular column not as the index
we try to set it to before we saved it
that's because a CSV file does not have
any attribute index okay this doesn't
happen so what we can do instead is in
basically all of these iOS so we're
doing read CSV but basically in any of
these um io kind of things like read
Excel hdf whatever you well AC is a
little different but read HTML or I
don't know Excel CSV whatever you can
specify the index column when you read
it in so we could take this copy paste
and then we could say index underscore
Col equals zero now we're going to print
it will print the old one and the new
one and then so this is the one without
it reading from CSV - this is the new
one bang so now we actually have the new
you know we're specifying date as the
index
next we have this kind of this value
column now that's all fine and dandy
when we know that we're working with the
housing price index for one data set but
what if we're grabbing the housing price
index from Austin Houston Dallas okay
we've got three well each column in
theory would be called value and then
you might have value XYZ or value one
two three and so on
that's a problem okay we need to know
what column that is so how might we
handle that well we want to rename the
column so one way that you could do that
is the following if you want to rename
every single column the way that you
would do that is you would say DF
columns equals and now we just have that
one don't forget because we set the
index and index is not a column it looks
like a column but it's not a column
anymore we've revoked its column status
so DF column is how we have one column
so we just need to name one column and
we're going to call that house actually
let's call it
Austin HPI house price index HPI DF that
caused us a HPI boom now print again DF
head save and run we have a bunch of
output here but the last one is Austin
HPI and you've renamed that column you
can also do DF rename and then columns
and the dictionary and stuff we will
talk about that later on in the series
now the next thing that we want to do is
save it to a CSV file so let's say we
want to save that so we would say D F
dot to underscore CSV and we'll save
this as new CSV three dot CSV fine and
good cool we should have a new CSV here
it is new CSV three open that up new CSV
- is refresh that's okay
here's new CSV three and you can see has
this new column header as Austan HPI
what if however you do not want these
headers in the file immediately okay
what if you just want this to be data
well we can
and for that so we can close out of this
and as you go DFT CSV let's copy that
paste will call its new CS before dot
CSV and what we can say is header equals
false
save and run that runs new CS before let
me pop that open real quick and now we
actually have no headers there at all
it's just the data cool now what if we
want to read a CSV back in that has no
header right because the other ones
about headers so what if you meeting a
CSV that hasn't heard so you would say
something like this like what if we have
DF equals PD dot read underscore CSV
we're going to read from new CSV for dot
CSV a and then we're going to say names
these are the names of the callings that
we have we know we have two columns so
the names would be the first one is date
the second one is Austin HPI finally we
know we want to set the index right away
so we've already covered that up here so
we'll just take this copy paste and that
just sets the index at zero the 0th is
the date so we're all set now we can
print efn save and run that pull this up
and that is from the most recent one
without any headers we name the columns
whatever the heck we wanted and we set
the index to be 0 cool so we brought all
that information in now what we can do
however is you can say you're reading a
CSV now as I was saying before you can
actually use pandas to be a sort of a
converter of data types so if you want
to convert from CSV to maybe XLS or
Excel X as I can never remember anyway
I'm going to convert it to say an Excel
you can do that if you want to convert
it to HTML you can do that so for
example I like to use pandas with my
databases a lot so my tables in my
database and a lot of times you store
information there I read it into a
pandas dataframe do whatever I need to
do I usually want to display it to like
a graph or something like that I do
whatever you need to do put it in the
graphing format that you want pop out
the graph to HTML data or usually you're
feeding a JSON into it
it just so happens that what pandas has
to JSON yup so anyway you can do all
kinds of stuff like that so like for
example reading in CSV let's convert it
to HTML what does that mean we're going
to do it's going to convert your pandas
dataframe to an HTML table that makes
the most sense the data is in table
format so how would we do that so we
would say DF to underscore HTML and then
we would convert that to example dot
HTML run that and sure enough there you
have example dot HTML we can open that
in chrome there is Chrome here we go
bring that over and here it is this is
your data frame ah that's pretty cool so
anyway and then if we open that we can
over that notepad plus plus so you can
see it indeed converted it to HTML we
can also do XML and all kinds of really
cool stuff close that out closing this
out now what we're going to do see if I
want to change anything else well yeah
actually what we'll do is let's read
let's do this let's say we'll cover a
renaming column the other way before we
close this one out so let's say DF
equals PT read underscore CSV will read
in new CSV for whoops we needed quotes
here new CSV for dot CSV will say the
names are equal to date and Austen
underscore HPI that's fine let's print
DF head we're not setting the index here
because we want to have two columns so I
can show you renaming just one column
because it's so far this other one DF
columns you'd have to set all of the
columns so let me go ahead I'm going to
comment out all these other data frames
because that's a lot of data frames we
already have this new CS before that's
been created so we don't need any of
that other information so let me run
this so there is your information date
Austin HP I also remember if I've said
if you want to bulk comment you press
alt 3 if you're an ID le all
for unconference just in case anybody
wants to know you do that really fast
anyway uh so there we go we have the two
columns now how do you rename a column
well you can say D F dot R M name rename
need to rename various things in here
one of the things that you could rename
his columns you say columns is equal in
likes curly braces and we've been using
Austin HPI
and then to rename it : what you want to
rename it with let's do 7 7 0 0 6h
underscore HPI
and then we'll say in place equals true
and then finally print d f head save and
run that boom you've renamed a single
column we retained date now of course
like I was saying you you would
obviously want your date to be the index
but we only had two columns that were
working with so I wanted to retain date
just so you can see that you could
rename one column at a time you know if
you if you really wanted to now moving
on into the next tutorial we're going to
be diving in a little deeper with real
estate investing and stuff like that
just just as an example you don't need
to know anything about real estate
investing it's going to be a pretty
upper level and by upper level I mean
not complex not intricate a tutorial we
probably will not stumble upon anything
that's going to make us billionaires but
the idea is just to have a kind of a
project that we can work around and
sample data to work with
anyways that's part three again if it
was really fast or whatever you want to
review it you can always rewatch the
video or you can go to Python
programming net all the tutorials are
there if you're watching the video the
sample code is all already there so you
can check it out follow along that way
if you want otherwise questions comments
concerns suggestions whatever leave them
below and until mister